Alice: Hey everyone, thanks for joining. Quick agenda — we have the migration
status, the mobile app cut, and the freelance contractor onboarding.
Alice: First, the OAuth migration. I'm behind on the design doc.
I'll have it ready by end of day Friday so we can review next Monday.
Bob: That works. Related — I finished the database backup verification we
talked about last week. Restored a test snapshot on Saturday, all clean.
Alice: Great, we can close that one. What about the index rebuild?
Bob: Still in flight — I want to wait until after the migration cut. So next
sprint, not this one.
Carol: Mobile app — we're cutting v3.2 on Thursday. I'll send the release
notes draft to marketing on Wednesday. One open question: do we include the
new live activity feature or hold it for v3.3?
Alice: Let's defer that decision. I want one more day of QA before committing.
Carol, can you bring it back tomorrow with the test report?
Carol: Yep, will do. I'll have the QA report by tomorrow morning.
Alice: Last item — the freelance contractor for the marketing site. We agreed
to bring on Sophie for the landing page rebuild. Bob, can you set up her
GitHub access by Friday?
Bob: Sure. I'll also need her to sign the standard NDA before commits.
Alice: Good catch. I'll handle the NDA paperwork — sending it today.
Alice: Decisions for today: OAuth design doc by Friday, mobile v3.2 cut Thursday,
Sophie onboarded by Friday with NDA signed.
Alice: Anything else? No? Great, talk tomorrow. Thanks all.